[music]
Valerie Smith:
Freshman Parents Weekend is a really special
time for us at the University.
Ebony Slaughter-Johnson:
I really enjoy showing my mom around the campus
and having her meet my roommates and my hallmates.
Valerie Smith:
The campus is really alive and buzzing, and
the family members are so delighted to see how
Valerie Smith:
exciting the students' lives are here at the
University. So, they get to see where their
Valerie Smith:
students live and work and socialize.
Ebony Slaughter-Johnson:
It's definitely a bonding experience for both
of us because I get to share what I love about
Ebony Slaughter-Johnson:
Princeton with her.
Alan Hatfield:
It's primarily directed to parents to let
them kind of get a glimpse of what life is
Alan Hatfield:
really like here.
Don Hatfield:
You see what these kids have and what they've
been given. They may not understand it totally
Don Hatfield:
right now, but they sure will one day.
Valerie Smith:
Freshman Parents Weekend is a wonderful opportunity
for parents to meet with their students' faculty members.
Cynthia Cherrey:
We know that all of your sons and daughters
that are here now as students have put a great
Cynthia Cherrey:
deal of time and attention into getting here,
and now they have the final goal of graduating.
Cynthia Cherrey:
But in between, we want them to truly experience Princeton.
Ebony Slaughter-Johnson:
I was pleasantly surprised that people
were so open and willing to talk.
Sanjeev Kulkarni:
The University has a number of events that
are always going on that are very compelling,
Sanjeev Kulkarni:
really exciting events, and it is a question
of balancing. Make sure you let your son or
Sanjeev Kulkarni:
daughter know if they're ever feeling challenged,
overwhelmed or need help, ask for help.
Shelley Slaughter:
I dropped a 17-year-old who had not been away
from home longer than a week here in September.
Shelley Slaughter:
She is maturing in a just phenomenal way from
the person that I dropped off just over six
Shelley Slaughter:
weeks ago. I can say truly that I'm a little
bit more at ease having spent this time with her.
Cynthia Cherrey:
They have been an amazing, amazing group,
and we're so excited to have them here. And
Cynthia Cherrey:
one of the things that I share with them is each
and every one of them is here for a reason
Cynthia Cherrey:
and a purpose. First is to get the most out
this education that they possibly can -- that's
Cynthia Cherrey:
the detours; those are sometimes the dead-ends
-- but it's to get the most out of this experience
Cynthia Cherrey:
in and outside the classroom. And they also
have a responsibility to give back and make
Cynthia Cherrey:
a difference at this place. A lot of the ideas
that you see being put in place happened because
Cynthia Cherrey:
of our students. So, thank you all for sharing
them with us for these four years, and I hope
Cynthia Cherrey:
you enjoy the rest of Parents Weekend.
[music]